donc c'est bien à l'heure de la revue de
presse à présent avec vous hélène frade
bien sûr bonjour hélène d'abord la
presse française qu'est ce qu'on en
retient ce matin quelques heures donc
après ce premier tour bis repetita sans
surprise un nouveau duel emmanuel macron
marine le pen attend les électeurs le 24
avril prochain annonce 20 minutes la
surprise c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
surprise le match mâcon le pen ce match
retour donc paraît-il les français ne
voulaient pas aura bien lieu ironise le
figaro qui estime que le président
peut-on envisager la suite avec sérénité
étant donnée son avance substantielle
match retour avantage macron le parisien
aujourd'hui en france évoque lui aussi
la sérénité des manuels macron qui
améliore nettement son score de 2017
après cinq années à l'elysée avec 27 6%
des voix ce qu'aucun de ses
prédécesseurs n'avait réussi avant lui
hors cohabitation
marine le pen qui réalise son côté le
meilleur score de l'extrême droite au
premier tour d'une présidentielle 1 3%
sur la progression en particulier et
celle du vote protestataire en général
inquiète la croix qui parle de
l'installation d'un clivage dangereux en
france et envisage un résultat second
tour beaucoup moins certain qu'en 2017
cette incertitude alarme libération
cette fois ça craint vraiment le journal
accuse emmanuel macron de s'être livrée
je cite à calcul cynique en participant
à la normalisation du discours populiste
d'extrême droite un calcul risqué pour
un second tour qui s'annoncerait bien
plus dangereux que le premier la menace
de voir marine le pen arrivait au
pouvoir n'a jamais était aussi grande
pas l titre l'humanité en appelant à
faire barrage à la candidate de
l'extrême droite au second tour à
l'unisson a d'ailleurs des candidats à
la présidentielle eric zemmour et
nicolas dupont aignan excepté encore
faut-il hélène que les électeurs se
déplacent dans 13 jours sans atteindre
le niveau historique de 2002
l'abstention continue de grimper 26% à
ce premier tour d'après mediapart cette
démobilisation sera au coeur de
l'équation pour le duel du second tours
est déterminante pour que la balance
penche d'un côté ou de l'autre des
terminaux sur l'a10 le choix des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon qui sort
par la grande porte selon le parisien
qui juge que le député peut se
satisfaire d'avoir été le seul à sauver
l'honneur de la gauche avec 22% des voix
le second le sort du second tour se joue
en grande partie chez les soutiens du
candidat de la france insoumise le monde
prévient également que la débâcle de
valérie pécresse la candidate des
républicains et plus encore celle
d'hidalgo pour le parti socialiste
limitent par ailleurs le réservoir de
voix d' emmanuel macron pour ce second
tour d'après libération marine le pen
peut quant à elle bénéficié du moins en
partie du report des voix pour eric
zemmour le grand dégager du premier tour
avec 7% des voix voilà pour la presse
française qu'elle réactions dans la
presse étrangère ni à l'image de la
presse française les quotidiens
étrangers prennent acte de ce nouveau
duel macron le pen à voir avec le
dessein de amman pour la tribune de
genève qui montre on le voit deux
électeurs quittant le bureau de vote au
dernier moment j'ai décidé de voter
comme d'habitude il un pareil ajoute
l'autre macron le pen acte 2 sans
surprise de france sont sortis des urnes
écrit le temps autres quotidiens suisses
de france pas irréconciliable espère le
quotidien qui pense que les français à
travers l'importance du vote pour
l'extrême droite et pour la gauche
radicale lancé un appel au secours et
que l'ignorer ou ne pas en tenir compte
ce serait une porte ouverte vers un
second mandat je cite en forme de
blessures au liban l'orient-le jour
hélène rappelle qu'il ya cinq ans
emmanuel macron promettait de
réconcilier les français le journal
estime que jamais depuis des décennies
nous pourtant semblé si divisée que
pendant le quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
des divisions dont le journal le rend
responsable 1 pour avoir cherché à
monopoliser l'espace républicain marché
la plupart du temps sur une seule jambe
la droite est incarné à tort ou à raison
la france d'en haut contre celle d'en
bas pour le journal belge le soir le
second tour s'annonce serré pour le
président sortant seul ou presque face à
tous les populismes
mis à part
deux noms sur les bulletins de vote dans
deux semaines cette fois presque tout
est différent prévient le frankfurter
allgemeine zeitung
le quotidien allemand s'émeut de ce que
les terribles images venues d'ukraine
n'est pas dissuadé une bonne moitié des
français de faire une croix sur les
anciens admirateurs du criminel de
guerre vladimir poutine je cite un
constat amer pour le quotidien qui
espère voir emmanuel macron se battre
pour son de réaliser et pour une europe
libre